the youngest plane
one cow tomorrow he's he's playing for
hell tomorrow yeah so you know what I
mean he he's playing for culture okay
so it means that he's going to make
another draw or no no
or he's going it means I'm speaking like
Nakamura
I'm not sure I'm not familiar with this
so no no but this is when you I'm not
familiar with the codes you know
streaming you should watch him this is a
really cool Church you know just
hahaha
yeah okay Charles this is your school he
plays on how tomorrow
this is a brilliant shot
but this was unbelievable I think it was
actually also in a year term work just a
year ago when I played this um Lindora
save a thing
and then somehow like I miraculously got
to to the final where I had to play
Hikaru and it was sort of funny like you
sort of play uh play along the of Chess
and then
I would normally get to my room like
tired
Ness
and then I go to the switch where Naka
would normally go to stream a little
and yeah that's okay shot this shot that
shot and watch out this was my favorite
thing
yeah
it isn't a very nice thing for just I
mean I'm becoming a big streamer but uh
still shots you know is there a
different horse shot no and coming back
to the pairings and what I wanted to say
that there is a very important game also
um waiting for us tomorrow between 5B
and Anish
so
um
ding is in trouble then yeah
so what to do
what to do you know
yes please send us actually some
variations maybe if Guinea will
um
be soon understood and give some
computer proposals but uh foreign
haha
okay let's actually go back together
yeah yeah but this is fun as a reference
is this a problem you know I mean the
time has changed I mean I I can get your
reference obviously but now I think
there is a number of people who can get
the as a reference to you know NACA
streams uh he's much much bigger but you
know that even we shall not knows the
reference
yes yeah but he he used this story once
in his community he knows about knock as
well yeah so yes let's get back to this
crazy position